Turkey is the pressing ahead with its
operation in northern Syria against
Syrian Kurdish forces now the Kurds have
lost the United States as their ally so
they've turned to Syrian dictator Bashar
al-assad who was moving his troops north
towards the Turkish border now we have
some of the latest footage here taken
from Syria looking across taken from
Turkey sorry looking across into Syria
where Turkish shelling of russel ain
continued this morning at least a
hundred and sixty thousand civilians are
believed to have fled the fighting in
the border area and they have headed
deeper into syria but opposition to
turkey's assault is growing US president
Donald Trump is opposing economic
sanctions to pressure Turkey to stop the
offensive and is offending vice
president Mike Pence to Ankara to try
and broker a ceasefire this is what
Penn's had to say about Washington's
aims the president's objective here is
very clear that the sanctions that were
announced today will continue and will
worsen unless and until Turkey embraces
an immediate ceasefire stops the
violence and agrees to negotiate a
long-term settlement of the issues along
the border between Turkey and Syria
let's go right to DW correspondent Yulia
Hahn she is not jacala on the Turkish
side of the border for us hi Yulia good
to see you the u.s. is now imposing
sanctions the vice president Mike Pence
is now on his way to the region what can
US pressure actually do here well there
are no signs yet that president edawn
will back down and end this military
operation despite the international
criticism despite the US sanctions even
though these sanctions might potentially
hurt an already weak Turkish economy an
economy that hasn't yet recovered from
last year's severe currency crisis now
Trumper raised
steel tariffs again back up to 50
percent that's something he did last
year already when he was pressing for
the release of an American pastor from a
Turkish jail he also issued sanctions on
three Turkish ministers and his
ended trade deal worth 100 billion u.s.
dollars now this did not have an
immediate a drastic effect on the
Turkish currency here but it might scale
of more foreign investors Julia you are
there on the Turkish side of the border
tell us what's been happening behind you
on the the Syrian side of the border
well just earlier today we heard a fresh
shelling and pounding very loudly so the
Turkish artillery is right behind me and
they're hitting targets there in
Northeast Syria I'm about five
kilometres away from the border on the
other side you have the Syrian town of
Talib yot it has been captured by the
Turkish military but apparently they are
still fighting going on in the
surroundings that's one of the main
targets the other main target is the
city of Arras a line still there are
heavy clashes going on there and we have
a new front line there in Northeast
Syria after the Kurdish led forces have
officially turned to the Syrian regime
for help and Bashar Assad has been
sending units of troops to parts of
northeastern Syria for the first time in
years because in 2012 the Kurds there
shrugged off Damascus as rule and the
Syrian government forces were actually
withdrawing now there are back there
facing the Turkish army along a new
frontline and this is essentially a
victory for Bashar al-assad and maybe
more importantly for his backer Russia
because now they have a foothold in an
area that was beyond their control for
many years Julie as all of the fighting
has been going on you've had the chance
to talk to some people there what have
they been telling you well public
support for this military offensive is
broad across Turkish societies across
the Turkish society not only president
Erin's AKP is supporting this offensive
but also other parties the only
exception is the pro-kurdish opposition
party HTP the media reporting is also
very much Pro offensive very nationalist
the media framing it as a security
operation aimed at combating a terrorism
threat across the border we've been
talking to people in the city of Ophir
near where I am let's listen to what
they had
we support this operation we stand with
our soldiers I hope turkey will be as
successful as it was in a previous
operation it will liberate these places
and enable people to breathe freely our
lives will be easier god willing the
border area has always been dangerous
because our country was invaded by the
PKK this operation is a great thing it's
wonderful otherwise terrorists will
threaten us and drag our country into a
war you remember that we stand behind
our president and our soldiers I hope
God will never take them from us now
those who feel differently don't dare to
voice criticism the Turkish government
has clamped down on critical voices it
has detained dozens of people for
critical social media posts in the past
day so right where we are here is very
difficult to talk to people and
understand their concerns because as I
said people are scared to voice
criticisms or even the slightest concern
about this military operation
GWS Yulia Hahn reporting for us on the
turkish-syrian border Thank You Yulia